David in 12 to 17 it sounds like a lot
yet it would only be the most in four
years counter infrastructure handle it
now it probably can it just depends on
where the Hurricanes end up going I will
see that normally hurricane tracks are
most common in the Gulf of Mexico in the
month of sep tember so next month is
probably the time period where if we do
get quite a few storms forming there is
the greatest risk for coming into the
Gulf of Mexico then exactly I want to
talk about the Gulf of Mexico because it
is an important region for us gas and
oil how impacted will they be again it
depends just on exactly what subtract
the storms take one of the things that's
working a bit against the intensity of
some of these storms is that we don't
have as much favorable conditions in the
Caribbean which the National Weather
Service had mentioned today so sometimes
that can work against the storm systems
from becoming strong enough to actually
cause problems for the platform's
themselves now that doesn't mean there
won't be evacuations that lead to a
stoppage in production but at the same
time damaging storms probably a little
more difficult to come by this season
David forecasts can often differ
substantially from what actually happens
how often have the forecasts been in the
right ballpark if you like well
hurricanes are definitely a tough beast
to forecast since they are you know
individual systems and so there is the
opportunity that we could we could come
in quite a bit quite a bit higher on the
number of storm systems coming in lower
though I would be surprised because our
personal forecast has been for 16 named
storms this year so we're kind of on
that high side of what the weather
service is calling for it this time
Davis Lori that is the world's second
largest producer of orange juice so how
will these hurricanes affect the region
and as well orange juice production well
if you get one that comes directly
across the region it could cause quite a
bit of damage and it's certainly been a
long time
since we've seen a storm system affect
the Gulf Coast or Florida so this is a
situation that statistically they're
there at greater odds of a strike but
again it's it's really up to exactly how
the atmosphere is tracking at any
specific time so once the hurricane
forms will have a much better idea but
until that happens we we just have to
mention that it's a strong risk because
of the number of storms are we typically
talking about sort of coastal areas are
you know inland areas and crop regions
are they free from danger well for the
citrus crop there's not much protection
for them because there's not a whole lot
of inland to begin with and there's not
any topography to really slow the storm
and weaken the storm as it comes across
so the citrus crop even if it was just a
moderate hurricane could still incur
quite a bit of damage how about soybean
areas or corn areas because they're
grown mainly in the Midwest what are we
seeing there well I mean if you're
talking about it from a tropical storm
standpoint the greatest risk would be in
the what we call the mid-south the Lower
Mississippi River Valley that region if
a storm like a Katrina were to track
into the area you could see flooding
rains associated with that and this time
of year they're getting ready for
harvest so that could be a problem from
that standpoint for the Midwest really
unlikely that it would play a
significant role it still looks like a
very good Midwestern crop coming in this
season